Михайло з позивним "Бастіон" - військовий Нацгвардії.
Він воював у складі бригади "Хартія" Гвардії наступу.
Під час відбиття штурмів отримав важке поранення руки.
Вибухово-осколкове. Тобто мені розірвало долоню, зап'ястя і променеву кістку.
Тобто там повністю ці всі кістки… їх просто вирвало.
У Харкові військовому врятували руку, хоча й був ризик ампутації.
Тепер чоловік хоче повернути її функціональність.
Звернувся в "Брасс", бо рука вже 4 місяці болить.
Там нерви розірвані, кисті, дискомфорт.
Тобто постійний біль. На даний час лікарі кажуть,
що можуть мені відновити функціональність руки -
це захват і поворот зап'ястя.
Так як зап'ястних кісток у мене там немає,
то я не можу розвернути долоню чи щось взяти.
Відновити роботу руки взялися троє німецьких хірургів - професорів
Мюнхенського медичного університету.
Вони приїхали у Перший добровольчий хірургічний шпиталь "Брасс" в Івано-Франківську,
щоб виконати реконструктивні операції військовим
з тяжкими кістковими та судинними ушкодженнями.
І обмінятися досвідом з українськими колегами.
На жаль, наслідки в основному вогнепальних, мінних або осколкових поранень
спричиняють багато жахливих дефектів.
Вони знищують все - кістку, нерв, судини, м'язи.
Завдяки дійсно хорошій роботі наших українських колег
це закінчується тим, що в основному дефекти покриваються,
але функціональність стає меншою.
Отже, ми намагаємося покращити функціональність.
Список тих дефектів, які би ми хотіли обмінятися досвідом,
це були три речі.
Це є пластика великих клаптів шкіри на судинному анастомозі,
це є заміщення великих дефектів кісток
і нарощення костей.
Це, власне, ті технології, які ми просили в німців про обмін досвідом.
Сам хірургічний шпиталь почав свою роботу за три місяці до повномасштабного вторгнення
як українсько-німецька клініка пластичної хірургії та урології.
Але війна змусила перекваліфікувалися:
працівники вирішили надавати допомогу постраждалим від війни військовим і цивільним.
Пацієнтів тут лікують безкоштовно.
Та знаходити фінансування для шпиталю стає дедалі важче.
Від початку повномасштабної війни тут, у хірургічному центрі
пройшло лікування вже понад 270 людей.
Це є захисники і захисниці в основному, я думаю, 99% - це військові.
Я би сказав, що більшість з цих 270 випадків були доволі складними
як на реконструктивну хірургію, бо, зрозуміло, ми не є перший етап,
ми не прифронтова лікарня.
Однак як на такий етап реконструктивної хірургії більшість тих,
що до нас попадали, були непростими.
Деякі бійці в нас лікувалися впродовж 5-6 місяців
і проходили цілу серію операцій одна за одною.
Завдяки німецьким хірургам двом військовим вдасться уникнути ампутацій,
каже український ортопед-травматолог Вадим Сулима.
Саме він відбирав пацієнтів для цієї місії.
Зараз ми знаходимося на четвертому етапі -
етапі реконструктивно-відновлювальному.
Практично всі потерпілі, які отримали складні поранення,
потребують цих складних операцій. Практично всі.
Чи це з приводу пошкодження нервів,
чи це з приводу пошкодження м'яких тканин,
а от якраз в перелік цей і входять ті пацієнти, яких ми відібрали.
Чи це з дефектами кісткових, чи це, припустимо, сегменти кісток, які втрачені.
Це якраз понад 70% пацієнтів, на жаль, з мінно-вибуховою травмою
і потребують такого реконструктивного втручання.
Один із них - Артем Васильєв, військовий 81-ої аеромобільної бригади.
Хлопець підписав контракт за 5 місяців до повномасштабного вторгнення.
А потім війна почалась, нас перекинули захищати місто Рубіжне.
Там билися десь два-три місяці.
Не змогли їх стримати, бо дуже багато їх було, а нас не так багато було.
Там співставлення: нас 16 чоловік, а в них по дві, по три роти. Отак от…
А потім Сєвєродонецьк, де мені прилетіло в ногу вже.
Нас там оточували, дуже сильно тіснили нас.
Не було навіть чим техніку підбивати.
І техніка нас просто давила, і ми відступали.
І в той час, коли ми відступали, мені якраз прилетіла куля в ногу.
Артем вісім місяців лікувався у Польщі, де йому врешті-решт сказали,
що єдиний вихід - ампутувати ногу.
Він не погодився і повернувся в Україну.
Військовий переніс 22 операції на стопі,
останню з яких провели німецькі хірурги.
У мене вона велика була після операції, напухла.
Я можу навіть фото показати.
Ну, а зараз вони вже підкоректували її, вона вже менша набагато.
Ну, і кажуть, що все буде добре.
Найголовніше, що в мене нога є опорою. Це моя опора.
Якби я не міг - краще було б її справді відрізати.
А так я можу ходити. До цього і бігати намагався.
Тепер захисник прагне відновитися, щоб продовжувати службу.
Треба, я ж кажу, прийти в форму. Ну, а потім вже до частини повертатись.
Війна ще не закінчилася. Ще треба багато роботи робити.
За три дні німецькі хірурги провели п'ять складних операцій.
Найдовша тривала сім годин.
І для Михайла це був лише перший етап операцій -
прибирання рубців і нашивання нової шкіри.
Далі буде реконструкція і відновлення функціональності руки.
Це зараз буде найважча операція і така ключова.
Бо в залежності від того, як вона пройде, вирішать,
чи буде подальша вже операція, чи можливо їх робити.
Якщо буде все добре, то йдемо довгим шляхом реабілітації
і відновлення механізмів руки.
Бо є простий варіант - це ампутація.
Відрізати завжди можна.
Тобто рано чи пізно, якщо щось не вийде, ну так вже...
Я морально готовий. Налаштований на це.
Я знав, куди я йду і що може трапитися.
Я хочу максимально відновити функції руки.
Скільки це можливо.
У мене донька, дружина молода, так що є до чого прагнути, є за що боротися.
За пів року німецькі хірурги обіцяють повернутися -
щоб провести нові безкоштовні операції
і продовжити обмін досвідом.
За їхніми словами, ця місія для них -
не просто робота чи допомога.
Це подяка українським військовим за захист.
Чому ми в Україні? Я б сказав: чому ні?
Звичайно, ми могли б допомагати постраждалим будь-де у світі.
Але ми знаємо, що українці борються за нас.
Тому ми маємо їх підтримати.
І якщо ми можемо зробити це гуманітарним шляхом,
то це найкраще, що ми можемо зробити.
Ми не хочемо доставляти тільки ліки.
Ми хочемо поділитися досвідом.